huh in this video we are going to talk a
little bit about source code what source
code in is where you'll see it and how
the computer makes sense of it source
code itself is the actual text document
that a programmer creates they type it
up it's letters it's numbers it symbols
if you give that to somebody and have
them look at that on their computer
that's not going to run their email
that's not going to be web browser
that's just a text document really um
now the computer has to have a way of
interpreting that and making something
really powerful run from it there are
two main ways this is done either an
interpreter or compiler now in every
internet browser that works has an
interpreter so javascript is run through
an interpreter to make sense other
languages like C++ are used with a
compiler that's unlike an interpreter
the compiler does all of its work on the
programmers end so they send out their
package there their product and it's
already been compiled it can already run
on a machine whereas JavaScript and
interpreter languages you just write the
JavaScript you don't compile it or
anything and the computer itself the
browser has a technology to interpret
that and make something happen there now
there are arguments this way and that
everybody has an opinion about which is
better and really it's a case-by-case
basis compiling languages and
interpreting languages are better at
different things as you know free code
camp we do focus on interpreter language
of JavaScript I also want to talk a
little bit about what open source means
just because it kind of fits in the
language here source code open source
free code campus open source as are a
lot of really awesome projects what open
source means is that all of their
documentation all of their source code
is open and accessible now you may be
thinking ok so what but what's awesome
about that is if you have something you
want to change about free code camper
some way you think it could be improved
write that improvement in and send it to
us a free code camp and maybe
implemented it's a great way to see
programs grow and websites and products
grow and a really really strong and fast
way because there are so many people
constantly seeing it and seeing how it
can be improved the one thing that is
kind of an unspoken rule with
open-source is if you're going to take
something and improve it for yourself
even if it's a piece of software you can
download generally you want to give that
back to the community give that
improvement to everyone else so that
they can use it to